I want to make one more note before finishing with this lesson. Remember how I
said before that we could write this as muss of Q minus muss of A equals 0 for
the hypothesis test. And likewise for the alternative hypothesis we can say
that the difference between them is not equal to 0. Instead of writing this as
a difference. We can just write muss of d, which means the difference between
these two population means. The null assumes that this difference will be 0,
and the alternative assumes that they'll not be 0. Then instead of the
numerator we had before, we'll have the difference between the sample means.
And then subtract 0. We're testing to see if this difference between the sample
means, is significantly different from 0. However, we could see if this
difference between the sample means, is significantly different from any value,
not just 0. Maybe we want to test if the difference between sample means is 6.
Usually though, we're looking to see if the difference is different from 0.
You'll get more practice with this notation in the problem sets. Great job.